[موسيقى]
في الحقيقه لا تزال محظوره على الورق وهذه
السياسه الرسميه
التناقضه او او خاصه مختلفه المناطق
النهائيه
والمحافظات
غير النعميه هو هنالك حتى رجال الدين الذي
يقدمون الدعم لهذه المنظمات
وينضمون اليها ولهذا السبب بشكل خاص فان
احزاب الجناحين اليمين والذين يحافظون على
جنده واضحه
خاصه
همم
اغلب الحكومات كانت يمنيه في هذه البلاد
بشكل اساسي
[موسيقى]
اركب بيان العمانيه
الدستور ولا يزال موجود على الورقه وقد
انتهت بشكل كبير جدا تحت حكم العداله
والتنميه الحكومه على سبيل تستخدمه
تستخدم الموارد العامه
الدين ومثلا ده همم المسلمون السنه في هذه
البلاد همم
تفضلهم الحكم بشكل ايجابي همم لا شك هذا
انتهاك لماده العلمانيه للمنظام السياسي
التركي
[موسيقى]